as far as I know the Invisible Man was
the only one that he saw he did not go
to see the rushes as they were called
them and dailies now because he told me
that the one time that he went he was so
horrified by his huge face on the huge
screen that he just never went back
again he was not interested in he was
interested in the process he loved
acting he loved working he he knew when
he came to California to do a film and I
had to hear him his lines as he drove me
to school every morning ten miles
he knew everybody's part he knew the
whole script before he came out here I
don't think very many people did that I
think he I think he thought it was
interesting I think he was pleased with
the fact that this was one of that this
was very innovative this was one of the
first films that they had done this kind
of special effects with and he he grew
up in the slums of London he was one of
twelve children all but three died from
malnutrition when they were children I
mean it was rough and he didn't he had a
cockney accent that was so strong that
when he talked with it I couldn't
understand a word he said not a word
so he would do that to make me crazy but
the interesting thing to me was that he
became I mean from what I understand and
from what I knew how I knew him that he
became a different person he became a
very elegant man with a really
extraordinary what they call the
mid-atlantic accent it was his voice
nobody else talks like that half
American and half English and little
cockney throw
just